What happens in the shop manic
experiences that Scherman has the experience of being reduced to a skeleton
first.
So death,
a death experience on very realistic death experience.
And then the next thing that happens is that he finds himself in a place where
he's communing with his ancestor,
the ancestral spirits.
And then after that there's the climbing of something like the ladder,
Jacob's ladder say,
and an encounter with God for all intents and purposes.
And uh,
it's very widespread,
um,
phenomena.
It's the world tree.
And I,
I've thought about this a lot,
trying to figure out what this,
yeah.
What this represents.
According to a Yakut informant,
that that's in Siberia,
the spirits carry the future showmen to hell and shut them in a house for three
years.
Here he undergoes is initiation.
The spirits cut off his head,
which they set off to one side for the novice must watch his own dismemberment
with his own eyes,
dissolution to the primary elements in some sense,
and hack his body to bits which are later distributed among the spirits of
various sicknesses.
It's only on this condition that the future Sharman will obtain.
The power of healing is bones then covered with new flash in his,
some Casey has also given new blood,
so visit death and resurrection experience that's associated with this show.
Monique ritual.
We're here in the presence of a very ancient religious idea which belongs to the
hunter culture.
Bone symbolizes the final route of animal life.
The mold from which the flesh continually raw rises.
It is from the bone that men and animals are reborn for a time.
They maintain themselves in an existence of the flesh.
Then they die and their life is reduced to the essence concentrated in the
skeleton from which they will be born again.
That's a good graphic representation of the experience.